Elon Musk the owner of Twitter and the
majority owner of Tesla I mean at this
point he's I don't even really know he
didn't create Tesla I don't know what
the right word is for what we describe
as Elon Musk being with regard to Tesla
that guy Elon Musk delivered a bizarre
interview to CNBC reporter David Faber a
guy who I used to really like and this
interview is a little shaky for Faber
but we'll talk about that Elon Musk was
asked what are some pretty reasonable
questions about listen of course you can
believe what you want to believe about
anything but does it really make sense
to be making these political statements
that are turning off huge swaths of the
population because don't you want
everybody to be buying Tesla don't you
want everybody to be on Twitter isn't
this what you need and Elon Musk taking
the approach of I don't really care if
it costs me any money let's listen uh to
the first clip this is really just weird
and I think it is important for us to
say Elon Musk has said he is autistic
and I think we need to be respectful we
we don't want to just say
the strange things Elon Musk
the the strange things that are coming
out of Elon musk's mouth are merely
because he's autistic I don't think that
that's accurate and I don't think that
makes sense it also is not often
discussed
that he said he's autistic and maybe to
some degree that does impact the way
that he relates to interviewers during
these interviews I don't know uh it's a
question that I guess should be should
be asked David Faber asks Elon Musk
about you know you're tweeting about
George Soros you're getting into
conspiracy stuff even anti-semitic stuff
arguably and Elon Musk says he is
pro-semite or pro-seminite maybe As
Trump might say it Okay let's listen
properly but I mean you know what you
wrote but you basically it reminds me of
Barbados he's like you know calm down
people it's just not like a face out of
it
he said he wants to erode the very
fabric of civilization and Soros hates
Humanity like when you do something like
that yeah I think that's true that's my
opinion okay but why share it why share
it especially I mean
why share it when people who buy Teslas
may not agree with you advertisers on
Twitter may not agree with you
um why not just say hey I think this you
can tell me we can talk about it over
there you can tell your friends but why
share it widely
I mean I I this is freedom of speech I'm
allowed to say whatever you absolutely
are but I'm trying to understand why you
do because you have to know it's Gotta
there it puts you in a in the middle of
a the partisan divide in the country it
makes you a lightning rod for criticism
I mean do you like that I you know
people today saying he's an anti-semite
I don't think you are no I'm definitely
I'm like I'm like a pro so much if
anything I I believe that probably is
the case why would you even introduce
the idea of that that would be the the
case I I mean it looks we don't want to
make this a George Force interview no
well no I mean but nobody forced him to
talk about George Soros either so this
has a little bit of a ring to like the
whole I love the Jews they're great
business people thing that we once heard
from Donald Trump in front of some
Republican Jewish group so I I don't
know I mean it's kind of kind of a weird
thing of David Faber who's the
interviewer happens to be Jewish and he
says he believes that Elon Musk is
pro-semite which is an interesting thing
to say uh I think that I am less
interested
in the particulars of what Elon Musk
believes versus what he says to get a
rise out of people
than I am about the real questions as to
what impact this all in particular the
Twitter ownership is going to have on
the discourse and dialogue in the United
States musk also doubled down during the
interview about his claim that there was
no evidence that the Allen Texas shooter
was a white supremacist of course the
guy had swastikas tattooed on his body
but Elon Musk I guess defends having
spread that conspiracy theory
but I mean when you when you when you
link to somebody who's talking about the
guy who killed children in a mall in
Allen Texas
you say something like it might be a bad
psyop I'm not quite sure what you meant
but
oh in that particular case uh
there was a
a
somehow that that's not not that the the
the the
artistic people killed but the it was I
think incorrectly ascribed via white
supremacist action
um which it seems to have been and the
evidence for that uh was some obscure
Russian website that no one's ever heard
of that had no followers
um and the
the company that came that found this is
bellingcat right and you know what Bella
cat does psyops right
I couldn't really even follow exactly
what it was you were trying to express
there nobody could yeah in part why I
was curious but I'm saying that I
thought the the the ascribing a two
white supremacy was bullied okay and and
uh and and that the information for all
right so anyway we've since learned you
know the the shooter had Nazi tattoos
swastikas all over his body so let me
address one other thing related to Elon
Musk people wrote to me after my Lex
Friedman interview and said David why
are you so soft on Elon Musk is it
because you own Tesla stock is it
because you drive a Tesla
um we've addressed this so many times I
I
first of all on the facts I've sold 95
of my Tesla stock and and I've sold it a
while ago now and I said that and even
when I had the stock it did not
influence the things I said about Elon
Musk number two I'm I'm sort of done
with Tesla in fact when my current lease
is up I think we're going to be moving
on to something very different uh but
but all of that being said I think my my
thing with Elon Musk is there are lots
of people falling into the cult of
personality debate with Elon Musk
whether he's this incredible savior or
the greatest right-wing evil in the
world yes he's saying wild dangerous
right-wing things I don't deny that I
think where I kind of stopped short with
Elon Musk is I don't think he knows what
the hell he's talking about and I think
he's basically been captured by the
people he's been hanging around in Texas
you know Greg Abbott and whoever else I
just don't know that it's worth putting
that much stock into the importance of
Elon Musk in this particular way let's
focus more on Twitter policy for example
than the things that Elon Musk says I
find them deplorable there's no doubt
about it I also think he's done an
incredible thing in how he's pushed
forward electric vehicle and Battery
Technology both can be true there's no
secret there's no there's no reason I'm
discussing musk the way I do it's not
because of the fact that I had Tesla
stock for a while or that I have a
little while left on a Tesla lease so
you could you can stop emailing me with
that stuff but a bizarre interview and
investors I Can Only Imagine
not exactly rejoicing after this
extremely strange exchange on CNBC if
you or one of your parents is starting
to lose your hearing you're not alone
about 48 million Americans have hearing
loss and only one in five people who
would benefit from using a hearing aid
are actually using one our sponsors MD
hearing create FDA registered
rechargeable hearing aids that cost a
fraction of what you typically pay for
example MD hearings new Neo model costs
less than 10 percent of what those
marked up hearing aids are being sold
for at most hearing clinics and the Neo
is MD hearings smallest hearing aid ever
no one will even know that it's there I
have a close family friend who uses MD
hearing and loves it she said it
performs better than any hearing aid
that she's used and it's far less
noticeable MD hearing even offers a
45-day risk-free trial with the 1 100
percent money back guarantee so you can
buy with confidence and they have a
special deal for my audience when you
buy a pair of hearing aids you'll get
them for just 149.99 each plus they'll
include a free extra charging case go to
mdhearing.com and use the code Pacman
the link is down below